[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon fils ce sont des proies
nous nous sommes les prédateurs
les garçons votre mère est morte
elle est morte parce que tu l'as mise
dehors des faibles le pouvoir appartient
au fort
la moindre faiblesse donne un avantage à
nous émir
tu le dis
il est faible comme sa mère laisse-le
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là
j'ai regardé la mort dans les yeux
et pour la première fois
j'ai vu qui j'étais vraiment
parle-moi de ce chasseur
on raconte qu'il établit un lien avec
les animaux pour traquer ses proies
une fois qu'on est sa cible
impossible de lui échapper on est 6 et
toi tu es tout seul vous êtes six pour
l'instant
[Musique]
pourquoi tu chasses mon père ne fait que
répandre le mal
j'élimine ce mal
tu es exactement comme notre Père tu
n'es rien d'autre qu'un chasseur en
quête d'un trophée
on est des assassins c'est pas ce qui
nous a appris
[Musique]
monsieur
vous avez les pieds dedans
t'es un gros malade tu as mis du temps à
te rencontrer
il y a un animal en chacun de nous
tu veux savoir pourquoi on m'appelle le
Rhino